ahora vamos a ver la idea básica para
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo de la
cantidad de expresiones que queramos lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
factorizar las expresiones lo más
posible ahora si no te acuerdas de cómo
factorizar un número puedes ir a mi
página ahí tengo varios vídeos acerca de
cómo hacerlo pero por el momento vamos a
factorizar estos números directamente
aquí 25 se puede escribir como 5 por 5 o
sea 5 al cuadrado y luego el 100 se
puede escribir como 4 x 25 pero 4 es 2
al cuadrado y el 25 también se puede
escribir otra vez como 5 al cuadrado y
finalmente el 18 es 6 por 3 pero el 6 se
puede factorizar como dos por tres
entonces tenemos dos a la potencia 1
3 al cuadrado que también lo podemos
decir como todos por 9 y ahora sí ya
vamos a encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo y lo vamos a hacer así vamos a
recorrer de izquierda a derecha entonces
empezamos por aquí en el 5 al cuadrado
vemos que también hay un 5 al cuadrado
en la segunda expresión aunque en la
tercera expresión no tenemos 5 pero no
importa nos vamos a quedar con la
potencia más grande de 5 que en este
ejemplo es 5 al cuadrado 5 al cuadrado
es la potencia más grande de 5 en estas
tres expresiones por cierto aquí a 5 le
llamamos la base y a 2 el exponente
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es seguir
recorriendo de izquierda a derecha y nos
vamos a fijar en la siguiente base que
en este caso es un 2 pero queremos el
exponente más grande de esta base aquí
tenemos un 2 al cuadrado buscamos en las
demás expresiones
en esta expresión tenemos 2 a la 10
nuevamente tomamos el exponente más
grande así es que en el mínimo común
múltiplo ponemos 2 al cuadrado nos
seguimos moviendo de izquierda a derecha
por aquí tenemos la base 5 pero está ya
la contamos otra vez tenemos la base 2
que ya la contamos y nos encontramos con
la base 3 no hay 3 en las otras dos
expresiones por lo cual este es el
exponente más grande así es que lo
colocamos en el mínimo común múltiplo y
listo este ya es nuestro mínimo común
múltiplo de 25 100 y 18 y bueno por
supuesto podemos calcular cuánto es este
número 5 al cuadrado es 25 2 al cuadrado
es 4 y 3 al cuadrado es 9 entonces 25
por 4 son 100 por 9 900 900 es el número
más
al cual pueden dividir tanto 25 100 y 18
900 es el mínimo común múltiplo y ahora
vamos a usar exactamente la misma idea
en este otro problema si tenemos
únicamente variables de esta forma el
procedimiento es tal cual exactamente el
mismo empezamos por aquí tenemos x al
cuadrado pero en la otra expresión
tenemos x a la 5
entonces en el mínimo común múltiplo
ponemos la base x con el exponente más
grande o sea con 5 y entonces las x ya
nos aportaron toda la información que
necesitábamos lo que hay aquí las tache
no es que las estamos eliminando
simplemente ya no las debemos de tomar
en cuenta a la hora de sacar el mínimo
común múltiplo luego tenemos una y en la
una de la potencia 1 el exponente más
grande estrés por lo que ponemos ya a la
3 y entonces ya no peleamos a las 10 y
nos vamos con las setas tenemos z a la 4
y z al cuadrado y el exponente más
grande es 4 entonces nos quedamos con z
a la 4 y listo ya tenemos nuestro mínimo
común múltiplo x a la 5 llegue a la 3 z
a la 4
y ahora cuando tenemos una expresión que
tiene un término entre paréntesis nos
tenemos que preguntar si la expresión ya
está factor izada lo más posible porque
por ejemplo en nuestro primer ejercicio
los números 25 100 y 18 no estaban
factor izados y eso fue lo primero que
hicimos factorizar estos números en
nuestro segundo ejercicio si estaba todo
ya factor izado y bueno en este tercer
ejercicio si están factor izadas de
estas expresiones pero en este ejercicio
quise poner unos términos entre
paréntesis para que vieras que aunque
haya términos entre paréntesis las
expresiones pueden estar completamente
factor izadas así es que vamos a
calcular
el mínimo común múltiplo por aquí
tenemos x1 entre paréntesis elevado a la
3 y en la otra expresión también tenemos
x + 1 entre paréntesis pero elevado a la
4 así es que nos quedamos con el
exponente más grande que es x + 1
elevado a la 4 luego tenemos una w
elevada a la potencia 1
y en la otra expresión no tenemos
ninguna w lo cual es similar a tener una
w elevada a la 0 y por lo tanto no la
vemos entonces ponemos por aquí una w a
la 1 también tenemos una ya a la 3 pero
de este lado tenemos una a la 2 así es
que nos quedamos con una a la 3 con el
exponente más grande tenemos z las 5
iceta a las 6 el exponente más grande de
6 así es que nos quedamos con zeta a las
y finalmente ese fue el mínimo común
múltiplo de esas dos expresiones ahora
si en lugar de tener estas dos
expresiones hubiéramos tenido tres
expresiones la idea hubiera sido
exactamente la misma así como en este
ejemplo de los números simplemente
tenemos que tomar el máximo exponente de
todas las bases que aparezcan en las
tres expresiones pero bueno ahora
supongamos que queremos sacar el mínimo
común múltiplo de x al cuadrado más 5x
x al cuadrado más 4 x más 4 y luego
tenemos una tercera expresión x + 2 a la
4 x x + 5 tenemos estas tres expresiones
x al cuadrado más 5 x + 6 la segunda
expresión es x al cuadrado más 4x + 4 y
la tercera expresión es x + 2 a la 4 x x
+ 5 ahora aquí tenemos algo muy parecido
a lo que teníamos antes con los números
porque estos números no estaban factor
izados y lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es asegurarnos de que nuestras
expresiones estén lo más factor izadas
posible
entonces vamos a factorizar las x
cuadrada más 5 x 6 se puede factorizar
como x + 2 por x + 3 y una vez que
nuestros factores son términos lineales
estos ya no los podemos factorizar más y
lo mismo sucede con x al cuadrado más 4x
más 4 se puede factorizar como x + 2 por
x + 2 claro que eso lo podemos acomodar
mejor de esta forma y me gusta
escribirlo así como x + 2 al cuadrado
porque de esta forma tenemos la
expresión entre paréntesis elevada a una
potencia que es muy útil si me gusta
estar buscando cuál es la potencia más
grande de una base el último término ya
está factor izado x más 2 a la 4 x
+ 5 y aquí otra vez es básicamente la
misma idea para encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo aquí tenemos x + 2 a la
potencia 1
aquí tenemos x + 2 a la potencia 2 y x +
2 a la potencia 4 y 4 es el exponente
más grande entonces nos quedamos con x +
2 a la potencia 4 luego x 3 elevada a la
1 no hay x más 3 en la expresión de en
medio tampoco hay x más 3 en la
expresión de la derecha así es que nos
quedamos con el x más 3 a la 1 entonces
ya me encargue del x + 2 ya me encargue
del x + 3 ya me encargue del x + 2 otra
vez ya me encargue del x + 2 pero ahí
nos falta el x 5
que también nos quedamos con un x más 5
a la 1 y listo ese es nuestro mínimo
común múltiplo ahora todo esto de
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo va a
ser muy útil cuando queramos por ejemplo
hacer una suma de fracciones como ésta
en este tipo de sumas lo que tenemos que
hacer es encontrar un denominador común
y para encontrarlo lo único que
necesitamos es encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo de los dos denominadores de las
fracciones así es que lo que hemos
estado haciendo es como el prerrequisito
para sumar y restar fracciones cuando no
tenemos únicamente números sino también
variables y expresiones más complicadas